à la tienne mon Bruno
France et franchement j'ai l'impression
que j'arrive la bonne année moi la
statue de cire du comédien a été retiré
du musée Grévin à Paris le don de
l'humoriste a également été effacé de la
liste officielle des personnalités
représentées dans le musée et ce pour
une durée indéterminée
plus rien quoi
Patrick Sébastien je suis toute
émotionnée je le sers comme si je le
connaissais ça fait 100 ans
attention j'arrive non stop
je te la tiens
pas j'avais des problèmes de vêtements
quand même j'étais un petit peu comme
Albator qui était quand même une
un héros androgyne c'est vrai j'ai même
rencontré des amis gays des amis
Ie S qui me disait qu'est-ce qui
qu'est-ce qui nous dit qu'elle va tort
et un homme et peut-être une femme
à l'époque puisque je mettais des robes
pour aller à l'école nous on le voit pas
la même manière
c'est impossible c'est impossible il y a
un replay c'est obligatoire
alors que l'auteur vient de décéder quoi
David il pense au chrono de nid et il a
raison
dans la performance
[Musique]
polémique est en train de parler
en athlétisme elles sont merveilleuses
elles sont tous les sports
le sport
reste masculin
et là c'est pas il me tend la pince
genre ouf toute seule donc là je me
enfle d'orgueil je me dis son 4 sur le
quai faut pas que je me rate
[Musique]
c'est lourd
ils sont morts de rire je crois qu'il se
moque de moi
plus vite plus vite plus haut
[Applaudissements]
plus vite plus haut plus fort il y a pas
une femme qui va plus vite qu'un homme
[Applaudissements]
c'est un couillon de Briançon ou un
abruti de chacun des Alpes oui Arnaud ce
sont les salariés de l'enseigne
Castorama donc qui ont dormi tout
simplement dans le magasin donc de
Strasbourg parce qu'ils sont en grève
ils demandent et bien tout simplement la
réouverture des négociations annuelles
obligatoires sur les salaires donc les
fameuses Nao ils demandent une
revalorisation de leur salaire attention
votre journée de travail est terminée
l'ordinateur va s'éteindre dans 10
minutes veuillez rentrer chez vous ce
message s'affiche sur tous les écrans
d'une société informatique en Inde une
des employés à partager cette photo sur
Linkedin ou l'initiative a obtenu plus
de 400 000 mentions j'aime mais sur le
réseau social professionnel numéro 1 là
où les team leaders et les coachs sont
rois certains ont des halters ça va
poser un problème comment cette
internaute
idem pour cette accro au travail qui ne
pourrait pas s'y faire tout est bon donc
pour dormir tout cela dans une relative
bonne ambiance parce qu'ils ont fait
quand même une partie de pétanque dans
la dans la boutique pour passer le temps
on se rappelle il y a tout ce qu'il faut
donc ils expliquent en fait toucher ils
expliquent toucher en moyenne 1300 euros
net par mois et demande à leur direction
une augmentation de 200 euros
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
prévu pour début mars le panier
anti-inflation du gouvernement
arrivera-t-il un jour dans les rayons de
tous les supermarchés un flou persiste
depuis les déclarations de Bruno Le
Maire le ministre de l'Économie a dit ne
pas savoir si ce panier de produits de
première nécessité à prix bas verra le
jour le gouvernement semble désormais
vouloir laisser la main à la grande
distribution et ben vous gardez ce
cadeau regardez un mec Bruno versez
votre boisson chaude et le beau Bruno
apparaît comme par magie un cadeau
vraiment très très hot
Elian je sais pas écoutez vous me verrez
au petit déjeuner en tout cas Maria nous
continuons travailler à là ou au
meilleures solutions possibles que ce
soit par le gouvernement ou par le
supermarché dans lequel vous rentrez à
la rigueur peu importe ce qui importe
c'est que vos courses vous coûte le
moins cher possible
c'est délicieux mais un petit tour de
moulin et ce sera parfait
chef
reprenez la main quand je vois le prix
de la viande regardez hier je suis allé
acheter un jarret de porc et de
saucisses pour me faire une protéine 18
balles
[Musique]
j'ai rigolé
fait chier nous même on a fait en
Espagne allez à 20 minutes de à
Perpignan tu traverses il y a plein de
porcherie je paye 20 balles de morceaux
de cochon il y a une nouvelle expression
qui circule en Grande-Bretagne on parle
du bruit great brexit brexit regrette
brexit
57 % des Britanniques votre ex pour
rejoindre l'Union européenne du coup des
Britanniques c'est ce qu'ils font du
coup pour manifester leur mauvaise
humeur et ben ils deviennent français
si tu vois le qualifier et en plus il
est autorisé ce vol par l'État et après
l'histoire de la guerre je suis désolé
ils ont pris ils ont pris cette idée-là
de la guerre pour augmenter les prix
partout mais quand quand le peuple
n'aura plus d'argent dans la poche il
aura plus d'argent sur le côté et bien
qu'est-ce qu'ils vont provoquer un
nouveau Mai 68 et là ça va être
carrelage dans la France comme nous ils
font des magnifices foutent en grève
c'est du jamais vu depuis 1979 vous
voyez au moment même où il commence à
nous ressembler et ben ils ont mis des
barrières pour qu'on puisse on aurait pu
faire la lutte ensemble